another big moment in season two the
cannibalism Jackie Feast oh sure yeah
just a little throw away moment
what do you mean what do you mean right
before lunch I'm sorry
Jackie fruit as nicknamed yeah
[Music]
what was it like being there I heard
that Jackie was really made of Jackfruit
I was like kind of tasty it was so hard
no I mean like the I mean it's it's a
good fruit but just for Jackfruit just
project it was just like so hard to
disassociate we were all doing it full
out and staring trying not yeah and it
just looked so real like when we were
pulling on the little rice paper and it
got stretchy and it it just picked up in
your mouth while you could it was also
like a sudden smell that was like the
rubbery the rubber oh yeah and they're
like oh yeah dig into the tissue the
tissue like I mean like there's just
moments where you're like yeah this is
all pretend it's all pretend and then
you're like oh my God but that does look
like Ella also like I was towards the
end you know the right end of her the
heads here I was over here and I was
just like I'm getting too close to it
like there's just too much happening
right now I did throw up on set
um it happened twice but during that I
threw up once that day
um just a little tidbit you guys were
all dressed up beautifully with the
outfits and then the juxtaposition of
them seeing the very raw moments what
was it like filming those two scenes the
banquet was fun being glamorous yes the
mannequin was not why it was very
disturbing it was very confronting I
think we were all caught off guard by
how viscerally difficult it was there
was there was some
some emotional weirdness that cropped up
for a lot of us there was some dry
heaving there was some like going away
and real vomiting a couple of people
actually did oh yeah a little too
lifelike yeah yeah but that's because
the it was just so well done like we
have an amazing props Department an
amazing FX and they made that body look
and smell
taste I don't know so real two very
different experiences shooting both
versions of that for sure why is Ben the
only person who abstains am I the only
person of those names
but I I truly think that it's more
because of what he sees in the girls at
that point
um and Travis it's not so much you know
an aversion to doing something practical
to keep ourselves alive it's more he
sees what comes over them and he is
reacting to this this kind of Trance
that they have entered and he realizes
that they are so far gone and he has so
lost control of this situation that he
has no choice but to start to kind of
back away from the rest of the group and
and just figure out how to now shift
gears into his own survival mode instead
of you know trying to be the kind of
protector and the leader and the
authority figure of this group you were
going after it what did that feel like
that scene uh was shot in two different
days so two very different Vibes because
uh the world in the woods as a group all
dressed up we're clean for once on this
show it was so nice and it was just it
was it was really nice it was such a
great day and then the day that we're
over top of that charred body feasting
Jackfruit as what we're eating and it
just so real yeah lunch is over for me
skipping lunch yeah it was really hard
to stay in it for very long we all were
like all right we're gonna take a break
uh we'll see in a few minutes between
each take luckily we got this bit of
Jackfruit and not actually eat it always
so the decision to bring Jackie back
what a treat for fans was that always
your plan or did you listen to the
outcry on the internet that people
wanted more of Ella and they wanted more
you know it's funny we try not to I mean
we certainly find meaningful the the
outcries on the internet but we try not
to listen too much because we have to
just trust our instincts and the writers
room and decide sort of what speaks to
us yes but we did have time at the end
of season one when we were in The
Writer's room to really think about
bringing back Jackie's character because
it made such a meaningful difference for
like where we would see Shauna at the
top of season two so it was really in
some ways about Shauna of course you
know Ella Pernell is amazing but we
wanted to say this is where Shawna is at
psychologically at the beginning of
season two and so I felt like a great
device through which to do that Ellen
knew that she had a one season series
regular role um and deal but as part of
that deal we had an option to bring her
back for a few episodes because
yeah we had this in mind yeah what did
you make
a Jackie fee
it's not gonna lie yeah I I saw her
comment I didn't want to give away too
many of my fan theories but
we're coming okay so as the person who
is responsible for Jackie are you okay
with that decision I gave you my full
consent
it's our blessing for the cannibalism
just enjoy it a little solo Peppa put me
on the fire it's fine we know that
Jackie was on the menu
um does that mean that others are
potentially going to be on the menu as
well oh no that's it we're done yeah
everyone do want to speak to that
because
because a lot of some of the audience
may think that it's a slippery slope now
to that being kind of where things go
but if you wake up from having done that
there's also another way to go which is
that they can all be filled with such
self-recrimination and guilt right that
they could say like we're never doing
that again no matter what happens we've
broken that taboo we'll never do it
again so I think if they had their
druthers they would not be eating each
other so it's not merely that the seal
has been broken
foreign
[Music]